we are taking your calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0
4750 let's go to our caller from the
five-seven one area code who's calling
today from 571 what's up there's
Federico hey Rodrigo what's up and then
I just wanted to ask you um oh it's all
like seeing the news and everything and
how like Fox and like oh we an and how
they interpret things versus house you
know else interpret things I just want
to ask you like how do you think future
generation is gonna look at this because
this is obviously like the worst
president maybe any country has ever had
yeah handling that's like you get what I
mean
I mean sort of an out-and-out
totalitarian murderer we've got a pretty
bad president right now yeah yeah just
like my question really is like how do
you think this is gonna like if you
shouldn't go look at this and this
pandemic make in the end and like how
that they're gonna view this president
in your opinion you know the pandemic is
harder to say but as far as you know the
retrospective on how Trump will be
viewed in the future my fear is and this
is ultimately going to come down to
historians to deal with my fear is that
because for everything Trump has ever
done there's always been a propaganda
counter narrative right so like if
twenty years from now you want to look
back and say what was being said about
Trump's handling of the virus at the
time what was being said about Trump's
Ukraine
you know corruption at the time what you
can it find people who defend Trump no
matter what he does so I worry that the
widespread availability of this at this
disinformation on the Internet is going
to prevent future generations from
accurately understanding the horrors of
what we are seeing right now I think
that that's a very serious concern yeah
- well David have France where they
talked about this I have no idea what's
really going on because all they watch
as folks use so give me an example like
is that it as far as the virus what are
some of the things your friends are
still saying
like the virus obviously being taken
seriously they didn't understand how
much Trump screwed up like we could have
solved like because the king of how
South Korea already has it under control
pretty much and we had the same like we
started the same day with the virus
right and they don't understand like to
the degree that Trump actually screwed
it up and like he just talks like
everything's under control and reports
lives about a serious it is and I'm just
afraid that they're not that I realized
how much like this person actually
screwed the country over its likely that
they won't now let me ask you this are
your friends who think Trump did a good
job are they also not really worrying
about the virus and just going out and
acting like they shouldn't be staying
home I'm pretty young guys so like you
know there's like 20 they're not really
concerned about it but yeah but yeah
some of them just like the lack of
information I guess so some people just
I guess nowadays just not watching it
and when they do watch they sometimes
get the wrong information that's all
they believe yeah yeah no I
this is a major concern it's good that
you're thinking about it because when
the history books are written about this
era we want them written accurately and
of course different people have a
different view as to what that means but
the amount of disinformation propaganda
could keep completely alternative
narratives about the Trump
administration going for you know
decades hundreds of years is it possible
and that's a scary thing because we've
got to learn from our mistakes very much
as David Rodrigo thank you so much very
appreciate very much appreciate the
phone call